["Take Me By Your Side"]
Guys, it's time to freaking close the deal, baby.
And everything, again, I've said this on the last video,
I've said this multiple times,
everything that we are doing up until this point
is leading us to this moment, okay?
And that's not to psych you out,
that's not to spook you out,
that's not to overthink it or get nervous
or get sweaty palms.
Guys, if you've done this correctly,
I need you to also remember as serious as this moment is,
if you've done this correctly,
this should be a piece of cake.
There should be very little apprehension,
very little in terms of objections and all that kind of stuff.
You're just gonna be relaxed, but be in the moment, okay?
I'm excited, I love this part.
This is literally what I live for.
And I will tell you that back
when I first started doing sales,
this part freaked me out
because I knew that I was going into a bloodbath
and they were gonna object
and I was gonna have to say these things
I didn't wanna say and all this stuff.
Well, guess what?
We do the setup correctly
so that we don't have to go through that, okay?
So one thing I want to mention really quick
before we hop over to the closing script
which we're gonna go through
is I wanna talk really quickly about rapport.
So as soon as the customer jumps onto the Zoom,
it's fine to spend a few minutes just like,
hey, how's it going?
Or maybe they have something on the wall
and you ask them a question.
But guys, I used to think like when I first started,
I heard about rapport
and I thought you needed to talk about fly fishing
or guns or trucks, golf, something like that
for 30 minutes to build rapport, okay?
And I realized that's not what rapport is.
Rapport is showing the customer
that you know what they're,
first of all, you care.
First of all, or second of all,
that you have what they need.
Third of all, you know what the hell you're talking about.
And fourth of all, that you know how to get them a result
and you are there for business, okay?
Above all, it's showing them that you're professional
and you mean business and you don't need to be rude.
You don't need to cut them off,
but you do not need to spend 30 minutes
talking about fly fishing or generators or food storage
or whatever weird thing they're into
that you can make a connection.
I know that people think that sales, it's not.
Sales is getting in saying, hey, look, Mr. Business Owner,
I wanna respect your time.
I wanna respect my own time
and I wanna get into this, let's go, okay?
They're gonna go, oh shit, this guy means business.
This lady, she means business and let's go, okay?
So don't feel like you need to do that.
I do occasionally, you'll notice in some of the videos
that I've shared or that I will share,
I'll see something, an African painting and go,
hey, just so you know, where are you from?
Okay, cool, I actually lived in Africa.
I make a connection, but it's not necessary
and I don't dwell on it, okay?
So let's hop over to the closing script.
Okay, guys, we are at the FFM Closing Script 2.0.
I'm actually really excited to say that this has changed.
So when we filmed module one live back in December of 2021,
we had a different script.
Now, it's very similar, but we have,
or when I say we, I have gone in, I have looked at this,
basically what was happening is I realized it was too long
and I was like, look, we gotta figure out a way
to shorten this up, this is taking way too long.
So I basically said, I'm gonna test this out
and I started doing the script,
but I started pulling chunks of it out, okay?
And I started testing it.
And after about a month of having the exact same result
and closing at a really high rate,
I realized I could remove a bunch of the script.
So if you guys have 1.0, you're gonna see
that there's stuff that's taken out of it
that I think that it was unnecessary, okay?
So this is the latest, the greatest, the leanest,
and I'm trying to continue to shorten this
because I don't think it needs to be super long, okay?
But what I wanna do here is I just wanna go through it.
I'm gonna have, and as you guys have seen,
I have tons of examples of me doing this live.
The best way to give you this example
and showing you how I do this is give you live sales calls.
And so I'm gonna continue to do that.
So I wanna just go through this step by step, okay?
So here at the top, I just have a couple of reminders.
I would recommend printing this and putting it off,
putting it on your desk and studying this thing
over and over and over because if you can learn this
like the back of your hand, you're not gonna have
to refer to it over and over.
And by the way, I will tell you that there are students,
I've watched some of your recordings of your first deals
and I have literally watched,
you look at the business owner over here
and read the script over here and still close the deal.
Like word for word, read the script.
So if you feel at any point you don't know what to say,
just go back to the script, okay?
It is very, very effective and very, very good.
Okay, I'm excited about this guys
and I do wanna say one last thing, not to toot my own horn,
but this is not a script that I Googled,
this is not a script I borrowed and built on.
I built this from scratch and I built this from scratch
based on the experiences that I've had,
based on thousands and thousands,
sitting at thousands and thousands of kitchen tables,
sitting on thousands, well not thousands,
probably hundreds of Zoom calls, soon to be thousands,
maybe we're close to thousands,
but this is a script that I've built,
tweaked, tested, torn apart, put back together.
It has been refined and refined
and will continue to be refined.
It is a living, breathing document and it works.
And I'm proud of that, but I want you to know
this is not a script that I pulled and said,
let me just tweak it.
No, this is from scratch.
I pulled open a document and I said,
all right, let's start building this out.
And it was a blank canvas and this is the masterpiece
and it works, okay?
So also note, this is the same script I used
when I launched this program to get the first 30 of you
to join the program.
It's also the script that every single one of you
that's got on a one-on-one Zoom call with me,
I have used this exact same format
to get you into the program.
So if you wanna talk about being sold on your product,
you wanna talk about a product that works,
you wanna talk about drinking the Kool-Aid,
I'm drinking my Kool-Aid,
because I'm literally using the script
to get you into the program that I'm actually selling you on.
So work that one through your head.
All right, let's go into this.
First thing that I do, I got a little asterisk here,
I wanna keep this video condensed, so let's go into it.
First thing I do, I take the pressure off,
I let them know, hey, I'm not the hard close guy,
I'm just looking to see if this is a fit, okay?
That is literally it and I let them know,
I'm like, hey, I don't have a big spiel for you,
even though secretly I kinda do.
I'm like, hey, I don't have a big spiel.
So just take the pressure off.
The less pressure they feel,
the better chance you have of closing it, okay?
And then I talk first about the purpose of the call.
So some points that you can choose to hit on
and you'll notice in my calls, sometimes I hit on them,
sometimes I don't, but I try my best to do it is,
some of the things I cover is, hey, look,
I'm not looking to do this for the next few months,
I'm not looking for a one month deal,
I'm trying to figure out if I can work with you
for the next 10 years.
I can make you money, you can make me money
and we can have a symbiotic relationship for 10 years.
So I'm looking to make sure this is a good fit, okay?
Just so you know.
And then I'll tell them, hey, my objective is to figure out
where you're at and you guys probably remember
some of this stuff when I was talking to you
because my objective is to find out where you're at today
and where you wanna go, okay?
And if my product, my leads can help you get
to where you wanna go from where you're at fast,
then we got a really interesting conversation
we're probably gonna be able to make something work.
And if it doesn't, Mr. Business Owner, I will tell you,
I will be the first to end this call and I'll end it early
because the time is the one thing that we can't get back,
okay?
Also, I put, here this kind of go in with that last point,
if my exclusive concrete leads help you achieve that goal,
that's the same thing, okay?
It's just kind of tied in.
Boom.
And then I also will sometimes hit on this a lot
and I'll say, hey, look, and I told some of you guys this,
if this isn't a good fit, I'm not gonna push it
because I'm not interested in trying to sell you
every single month on why you should stay with me,
why you should be with me.
I want somebody that's in this for the long run
and I wanna make a lot of money together, okay?
And then this is very, very important.
My only ask, this is why I put it in italics, okay?
And you can say some version of this.
Don't put pressure, but say something to this extent
is I say, hey, like I told you,
my only ask is this, man, or lady.
I've got a call in a couple hours.
All I ask is that at the end of this, if this is a fit,
let's rock and roll, let's shake and bake, let's do this.
I truly believe money loves speed.
I might even be wearing a sweater.
So all I ask, if this makes sense, let's do it.
Let's not hobnob around and you leave me in I don't know zone.
That's the only thing I ask, okay?
And also, if it's not a fit, just tell me straight up,
I'm a big boy, I'm a big girl,
you're not gonna make me lose sleep.
That's my only ask.
We on the same page, okay?
That's basically me saying, hey, look, bro, look, lady.
All I ask is that you give me a yes, no at the end of this,
but I'm saying it in a little bit different way
so I'm not adding the pressure, okay?
So first thing after you kind of set the stage
is I wanna learn about their company.
Guys, get interested in this part, enjoy this part.
Get a piece of paper, get a pen.
I have a yellow notepad sitting there in my remarkable.
And I literally, I tell them, I say,
I wanna learn just a little bit.
I wanna ask you a couple questions
to figure out where you're currently at.
And these are the questions I'll ask.
I'll be like, hey, and I'll tell them,
hey, I don't wanna be weird, I don't wanna be intrusive.
I wanna know these things
because I wanna find out where you're at
and then where you wanna go.
So just so you know, I'm not trying to peek
into your life too much, but it does matter to me
because I wanna see if I can help you, okay?
So some of the stuff I will ask them, what's your, hey,
so tell me, how much revenue did you do last year, right?
How much, how much, okay?
And I'll say, so okay, cool, you did a mill last year.
What do you wanna do this year, okay?
And then I'll ask them like, how does,
so like, how does your business make money?
Like tell me, I know you're in concrete.
Do you do more of the commercial jobs?
Do you do more of the residential?
How are you currently getting your business?
Like all of those things, I just wanna find
as much information as I can
so that I can figure out if I can actually help them.
Because if they start telling me, hey,
all we're looking to do is get commercial jobs.
First of all, I should already know this by now
and that's probably not a good fit
because most of these leads aren't commercial.
But if they sit there and go, hey,
we're plenty good on residential.
We only want commercial.
I'm gonna tell them, hey, just to be honest with you,
Mr. Business Owner, Mrs. Business Owner,
most of these jobs, 75% of them are gonna be residential.
So if that's gonna be an issue, I'm not gonna lie to you
and tell you they're all gonna be commercial.
There are gonna be some, but I don't wanna waste your time.
A lot of this is gonna be residential.
However, I will tell you this.
When you have an overflow of residential concrete leads,
you can do something called cherry picking,
which is charging premium and pick the best jobs.
Excuse me.
Having too many leads is not actually a bad thing, okay?
I also ask them, what's the end goal?
And again, guys, my biggest thing with this
is because you can add questions,
you can take questions away,
find out what makes them tick
and what's important to them.
And they're gonna give you,
this is a really important question
because they're gonna give you some bullshit answer
and say, well, I wanna make $2 million a month, right?
I wanna get the five million, okay, cool.
Why?
And Mr. Business Owner, I don't want you to feel
like I'm being that just weird,
but why do you wanna get there?
What is it actually?
You wanna get the five million, why?
Because do you wanna be, is it a recognition thing?
Do you wanna prove somebody wrong?
Do you have a vendetta for somebody?
Is it your old boss?
Or do you wanna go golf?
Do you wanna go and spend more time with your family?
Do you wanna be able to start other businesses?
They love talking about this stuff
and it's really interesting if you actually care
to find out.
And you guys know, I ask you the same thing.
I'm like, hey, what do you wanna do?
Okay, I wanna get to 10K, I wanna get to 50K.
Cool, cool story, bro.
Why do you really wanna get to 50K?
What do you wanna do?
Is it just one big F you to the world
that you just wanna prove everyone wrong
and get a chip on your shoulder?
If so, awesome, tell me about it.
I'm right there with you, man, and that's the truth.
Do you wanna go play golf?
Do you wanna be Tim Ferriss and go sip my ties on the beach
and have people rub lotion on your belly?
I'm cool with that, just tell me about it.
Like, I wanna be able to help you get there, okay?
And ask them and really, really care.
And it's important that you dig into their why, okay?
Now, you don't need to go so deep
that it feels like you're doing a therapy session,
but I want, get them to start talking real with you, okay?
Get them to start sharing something
other than I wanna get to 5 million.
That's like, oh, that's such a surface level goal.
Guess what?
I wanna get to a million a month.
I wanna get to 10 million a month, okay?
But it's so much deeper than that,
and I've told you guys, I wanna get those moments
where I set these goals that I never thought I could hit
and I hit them.
I want a Rolodex of exhausted but satisfied moments.
I know what my thing is.
I know what my why is, so it'd be really easy to answer.
A lot of these guys don't know, or a lot of these girls,
you gotta dig in, okay?
So, once we've gathered all that, say awesome.
And then what we're gonna do
is we're gonna start sharing the screen,
but I put right here, preface the pitch, okay?
So I share the screen and I don't share it until now
because maybe you have the script pulled up or whatever.
Make sure everything's clean and go,
okay, hold on one second.
Let me go ahead and share my screen.
Make sure you can see this.
This is why I wanna be on a desktop.
And you're gonna preface the pitch, okay?
So, first thing you're gonna do is you're gonna go,
just so you're aware, our objective is we go into markets
that are low-hanging fruit.
Essentially, the reason I got ahold of you
and the reason we're targeting Queen Creek
is because there's a lot of people looking for concrete
and there's not a lot of competitors
because everybody wants to go after Phoenix.
So we have this really cool opportunity.
That's why I'm calling you, just so you know.
I don't call everybody.
I'm not calling somebody in Mesa
and somebody in Glendale and somebody here and there.
I'm looking at Queen Creek
and I'm gonna work with one person exclusively
because there is an opportunity
that either you're gonna take or somebody else is gonna take
and I'm excited about it, okay?
So you're gonna preface it and you're gonna tell them,
just to be candid with you, as I told you before,
I've been reaching out to the best companies
that look like the best fit
and we wanna work exclusively with one company.
Again, you're planting these seeds, right?
You wanna let them know you work exclusively, okay?
All right, one thing I did note here as a reminder
is the sell through the client.
So, and I'm gonna talk about that in greater detail.
We have live streams that we've done on this concept
but anyway, you're gonna wanna sell through the clients
and instead of it being like, oh, if they ask a question,
instead of you handling it saying, oh yeah,
here's the answer, you're gonna go, hey, great question.
That's exactly what my client Joe in St. George
had the exact same question and here's what he discovered.
Remember that?
He also felt found and also selling through the clients.
Sorry about that, guys.
Anyway, so let's keep going, okay?
So the first thing, once I share the screen,
I'm like, all right, so let me show you something
and I come over here and I reemphasize
the market monopoly strategy.
Keep in mind, we have already shared this to some extent
in our pre-closed screencast.
So this is just reminding them, keeping it top of mind, okay?
One thing I totally left out and I, by the way,
I want this, like this is just how it is.
I kind of spaced it.
I want to make sure you guys remember.
Don't forget at the very first of the call
to make sure they watch the screencast, okay, that you sent
because if they haven't watched it,
and you should know because you should have tracked it,
but double check and make sure they watched it
because if not, that was a waste of time, okay?
And you're gonna have to overcome a lot of objections
that should have been covered in that, okay?
So first thing I do is I show them something like this.
I explain the monopoly strategy, okay?
And I don't need to go into too much detail.
You guys know what that is.
Basically more digital properties equals more money
is that's winning the game, okay?
And I'll show an example site.
So here I'm like, look, I work with a company
called Montgomery Construction.
As you can see, they're actually not even ranked,
but luckily I've been able to rank my homepage.
I've been able to rank the Google My Business
and I actually just noticed this.
I also have my Facebook page.
So I've been able to capture three
of the top 10 organic spots plus one map listing,
three in total.
So I'm almost banging down 33% of all the real estate
on page one.
That is why I'm winning, okay?
So I covered the market monopoly strategy.
I show an example.
And then you can also show, just really briefly go,
hey, and just to give you an idea of what this looks like
once we get to page one, this is the leads from June, okay?
And I'm not even gonna sit here and sometimes I will.
I'll go one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine, 10, and I'll go 11, 12, 13, 14.
You get the point, right?
There's a lot of leads coming in and it is only,
it's not even through the end of the month, okay?
So I'll show them those three things.
I'll show them the example,
I'll show them the Bentonville concrete example,
and then I'll show them the leads if you have them.
Guys, you don't have to show the leads
if you don't have them, okay?
Don't worry about that, okay?
So market monopoly strategy,
and then I mean, I go really deep into that.
Like that is basically it.
So I'm gonna show them that,
I'm gonna show them the site,
and then I'm gonna show them the leads, okay?
And then what I ask them is a really important question.
I say, hey, do you have any questions
about like how this works, anything like that
before we go into price, okay?
Or cost, whatever.
And they might, and this is where they might ask a question
and it might give you some insight
into what they're thinking, okay?
And then what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna explain
and I'm gonna go, hey, like the video
that I sent you yesterday,
so just real quick to understand
why we structure this how we do.
We don't do commission or paper lead.
And I'm sure you can understand,
commission does not make sense, period.
Like we just don't do it.
And just cut it off, say it bluntly,
we do not do commission, never have.
Doesn't make sense, you have no skin in the game,
I have no incentive to get you leads.
It's a dumb model.
Now let me tell you, we used to do paper lead.
And let me tell you what happened, okay?
And I will share the example of the client that I had.
We started on paper lead, it was X amount per month.
I thought it was gonna be the sky's the limit.
Ended up that it wasn't.
They ended up canceling or they ended up bickering
and trying to beat me down on price
and this lead and that lead.
It just didn't work out.
So here's why we do what's called flat fee, okay?
And we put it on a pedestal and we explain it, okay?
And flat fee is the best.
And guys, you need to get sold on the fact
this is the best case scenario for you, of course,
because of the cards on file, but for them as well.
Because when your site does rank
and they go from 12 to 15 leads to 30,
are they really gonna be wanting to pay triple
what they started at?
Hell no, okay?
So it's good for everybody.
Okay, then what we're gonna do is we're gonna open up
the lead value calculator, okay?
And if you don't know or if you wanna wait,
you've done this a few times,
you can go ahead and put their numbers in here.
But I've already done that.
So we're gonna open this up
and we're gonna walk them through it, okay?
And explain that the price that we're gonna charge
or we're about to drop,
it is not based on how I'm feeling right now.
It's not based on what I think you can afford.
It's based on a mathematical equation, okay?
And so here's what we're gonna say.
So I put, explain the goal.
Sorry, explain that the goal is to come up with a price
that even with the worst case scenario,
Mr. Business Owner,
even if that worst case scenario happens,
you're still gonna make money, okay?
And explain that to them.
So to explain, hey, what if we do a deal
and there's, whatever, something crazy happens
and the leads are a little bit slow
and we only get you 10 to 12 leads per month.
That's what I'm basing the price off of.
I'm not basing it off of what if I do
what I did in Bentonville Concrete,
which is probably pretty likely, okay?
So explain that this price is based on worst case scenario
and then you're going to put the number in.
Say, hey, look, what I did is I calculated
and I said, what happens if I only get you 12 leads, right?
Well, based on these numbers right here,
even if I get you 12 leads,
Mr. Business Owner, Mrs. Business Owner,
you're gonna make $18,000 in gross profit per month, okay?
With 12 and I just showed you what's possible, okay?
And again, I don't even wanna do that
because some of you guys are gonna go,
oh, I don't have leads.
I'm showing them the leads and what's possible
because I have it, but if you don't have it,
you don't need to show them that, okay?
You don't need to worry about that.
And so, and say, Mr. Business Owner, Mrs. Business Owner,
at that price, or sorry, at 12 leads, only 12 leads,
you're still looking at $3,600 in net profit, okay?
And then what you're gonna do is you're gonna drop price.
You're gonna come over here
and you're gonna go, based on the numbers,
the price is $2,000 per month,
which we either do monthly or we do weekly,
and then, or you can insert price,
and here's the cool part, you get 100% of the leads.
You get 100% and they're all exclusive, okay?
You get 100% of the leads, they're all exclusive,
and then I put, just so you know,
it is gonna be a little bit slower in December
because of Christmas, okay?
This is me overcoming a future objection.
It is gonna be a little bit slower
because of Christmas in December, but guess what?
In the spring and in the fall, sometimes in the winter,
you're gonna see a huge uptick in leads,
and I'm not gonna come banging on your door
asking you for more money.
All I ask is don't call me on Christmas and bug me
because it is gonna slow down a little bit,
but that's the beauty of the flat fee, okay?
Okay, last thing is explain
that you have a six-month agreement.
So I say, so it's really simple.
Like I said, it's only 2,000 bucks per month,
or you can do it weekly at 400 bucks a week,
sorry, 500 bucks a week, and what we typically do
is I don't like to start with some two,
even a year contract.
I like to start with something that's at least long enough
to give this thing a fair shake,
but it's not so long that either of us feel tied in
because who knows, maybe in a few months
I find someone I wanna work with better.
Maybe you don't like the way I work
and I don't wanna be tied in forever.
However, I do need you to commit
to at least some period of time
because look, I'm committing to you
to be 100% exclusive, so it makes no sense
for you to be able to walk away at any time
because I'm not going and building other relationships.
I'm not talking to other business owners.
I'm married to you, and I need you to be married to me
at least while we're working together.
So what we do is a six-month deal.
At the end of the six months,
my intention is that we roll this into another year,
but at the end of the six months,
if you don't like it, it's no problem, okay?
That's how I explain the contract.
And guys, do not hesitate to bring up contract.
Do not be scared to bring up contract.
Do not bring it up timidly.
If you bring it up timidly, they're going to see that,
they're gonna sense it, and they're gonna exploit it, okay?
They're gonna say, yeah, hell yeah, I have a contract.
Like, what do you think this is, okay?
Like, that's the mentality.
Yeah, of course I have a contract.
I'm gonna be exclusive with you.
What do you expect, right?
That I'm exclusive with you, but you have no,
like, you can walk away at any time.
That makes no sense, okay?
No sense at all, okay?
Anyway, just explain that you have a contract,
and then here's what I do,
is I explain everything one more time that comes with it.
So we drop the price, okay?
So if you guys notice,
this is what we call a shit sandwich.
At the beginning, we're talking about the case studies
and how good it is, that's the bun, right?
So we got the bun, that's the good,
this is the case studies,
this is all the leads that we've gotten,
here's the results, blah, blah, blah,
and then the shit, which is the price,
because as much as I don't wanna say it's the shit,
it's what they're gonna have to pay, right?
So that's the patty.
So you got the bun, which is good,
you got the shit, which is the price,
and then you wanna add a bun,
that's the shit sandwich, to complete it,
you wanna add the bun before you ask for price.
So what you're gonna do,
is you're gonna lay out everything that they get,
before you go for the close,
which I'm gonna save for the next video,
and I will see you there.
["Safe By My Heart"]